Nearly a century ago, Heler Bellac, a
European intellectual and historian,
made a remarkably prophetic observation
concerning Islam. Millions of modern
people of the white civilization, that
is a civilization of Europe and America
have forgotten all about Islam. They
have never come in contact with it. They
take for granted that it is decaying and
that anyway it is just a foreign
religion. That which will not concern
them. It is as a fact the most
formidable and persistent enemy which
our civilization has had and may at any
moment become as large a menace in the
future as it has been in the past.
That's from his book, The Great
Heresies. Few heeded Belellock's
scaremongering. Sound familiar? And as a
result, Islam is now the scourge of
Europe, especially in those two nations
from which Bellac's own family hailed.
France paternal side and England
maternal. Anyone who doubts his claim
would do well to familiarize themselves
with Islam's long record of violence
visav the West. And that's what I'm
going to do here in this video. Give you
a brief summary of how Islam has indeed
been the quote most formidable and
persistent enemy of the West. Actually,
because I use this quote in my book
Sword and Scimitar, I'm also going to
trace this long history of hostility
around the most pivotal battles between
Islam and Christendom as I did in the
book. Okay. According to Islamic
history, in 628, the Arabian founder of
Islam, Muhammad, called on the Eastern
Roman Emperor, Heraclus, the symbolic
head of Christendom at the time, to
recant Christianity and embrace Islam.
The emperor refused. Jihad was declared,
and the Arabs invaded Christian Syria,
defeating the imperial army at the
pivotal battle of Yarmmuk in 636. This
Muslim triumph enabled the Arabs to
swarm in all directions so that less
than a century later they had conquered
the greater, older and richer part of
Christrysendom, including the entire
Middle East, Egypt, and all of North
Africa. The Muslim drive into Eastern
Europe was repeatedly frustrated by the
walls of Constantinople. However, after
the spectacularly failed siege of 717,
many centuries would pass before any
Muslim power thought to capture New
Rome. The Arabs did manage to invade
Western Europe and conquered Spain, but
were stopped at the Battle of Tours in
732. For more than two centuries
thereafter, Islamic forces continued to
pummel Europe by land and sea. Untold,
thousands of Christians were enslaved
and every Mediterranean island sacked in
the ongoing Muslim quest for booty and
slaves as what was once called the Dark
Ages descended on the continent. The
facicissitudes of war ebbed and flowed
with the Eastern Roman Empire even
making a major comeback against Islam in
the 10th century. Though the border
largely remained the same, this changed
when the Turks under the leadership of
the Seljuk tribe became the new
standardbearers of the jihad. They
nearly annihilated eastern Anatolia,
particularly Armenia and Georgia in the
11th century, massacring, according to
the sources, tens of thousands of
Christians and enslaving even more,
especially after the battle of Manzuker
in 107 in 1071. At that point, they
overran Asia Minor, engaging in even
more atrocities, including the
systematic destruction of thousands of
churches. Again, according to the
sources, by then, however, Western
Europe's military might had so matured
that when the Pope Urban II called on
the Knights of Christendom to come to
the aid of the Christian East, the first
crusade was born. Western Christians
marched into the Beast Lair, defeated
their adversaries in several encounters,
and managed to establish a firm presence
in the Levant, including in Jerusalem,
which they recaptured in 1099. only to
lose it less than a 100 years later
after the fateful battle of Hatton in
1187. And a little over a century after
that in 1291, the crusaders were
eliminated from the Middle East. But if
it failed in the east, the crusade
succeeded in the west. A handful of
years after the aforementioned Muslim
invasion and conquest of Spain around
7-Eleven, fugitive Christians hold in
the northern mountains of Aurora began
the reconista, the reconquest. By 1085,
it had proven effective enough to prompt
two new Muslim invasions from Africa to
counter it. Again, the eb and flow of
war dominated the landscape. But by
1212, at last Navas de Tuloosa, the
battle of Las Nastas de Tuloosa, Spain's
indigenous Christians gave Islam its
death stroke. So that by 1252, it was
confined to tiny little Granada at the
southernmost tip of the Iberian
Peninsula.
Around that time, a violent but
relatively short-lived Mongolian storm
overwhelmed much of the east. Both
Christians, notably Russians and other
Slavs, and especially Muslims were
pummeled. A new Turkish dynasty arose
from the Seljic ashes. The Ottomans,
whose identity revolved around the
concept of jihad more than any of their
predecessors, which is saying something,
renewed Islam's perennial war on
Christendom. They managed to enter
Eastern Europe, defeated a combined army
of crusaders at Nicopolis in 1396, took
much of the Balkans, and in 1453 crowned
their achievement by fulfilling
Muhammad's dream of conquering
Constantinople, enslaving and graping
thousands of its inhabitants in ways
that ISIS tries to mimic. But mourning
was soon tempered by joy. To the west,
Spain finally conquered Granada in 1492,
thereby snuffing out Islam as a
political power altogether. To the east,
the most overlooked chapter of Muslim
Christian conflict was also coming to an
end. The Russians, who had lived under
distinctly Islamic rule for nearly two
centuries, finally cast off the
so-called Tatar yoke in 1480. Even so,
the Ottomans continued to be the scourge
of Christendom. They made inroads into
Europe, reaching but failing to capture
Vienna in 1529 and sponsored the seaborn
jihad originating from North Africa.
While the Muslims largely failed to
capture new European lands, so-called
barbar pirates and Crimean slavers
captured and sold many millions of
Europeans. In 1683, more than 200,000
Ottoman Turks attempted to take Vienna
again. Even though their failure marked
the Ottoman Empire's slow decline,
Muslim slavers of the so-called barbar
states of North Africa continued to
wreak havoc all along the coasts of
Europe, reaching even distant Iceland
and hauling off its wretched people in
chains to be sold in North Africa.
Indeed, the United States of America's
first war, which it fought before it
could even elect its first president,
was against these Islamic slavers. When
Thomas Jefferson and John Adams asked
the Barbar's ambassador why his
countrymen were enslaving and torturing
American sailors, the ambassador wrote
Jefferson in a letter to Congress quote
told us that it was founded on the laws
of their prophet that it was written in
their Quran that it was their right and
duty to make war upon non-Muslims
wherever they could be found and to make
slaves of all they could take as
prisoners.
This incidentally was a paraphrase of
Quran 95, also known in Islamic
juristprudence as the sword verse.
Europe's final triumph over the Barbary
states in the early 1800s, ushered in
the colonial era. By 1900, most of the
Muslim world was under European control.
By 1924, the more than 600-year-old
Ottoman caliphate was abolished, not by
Europeans, but by Muslim Turks, as the
la as the latter sought to emulate the
successful ways of the West. Islam was
viewed as a spent force and virtually
forgotten until recent times when it
reemerged again. Such has been the true
and most general history between the
Islamic and Western worlds. This map
should give you an idea of how
farreaching and multi-entacle this
perennial jihad was. The darkest green
shading represents Christian nations
that were permanently conquered by
Islam. The lighter green shading
represents those Christian nations that
were temporarily conquered by Islam,
sometimes for centuries, as in Spain,
Russia, and the Balkans. The green
stripes represent areas that were raided
often repeatedly. They were the no man's
zone often times though not necessarily
annexed by Islam. The cross swords mark
the sites of the eight most landmark
battles between Islam and the west that
I just mentioned. Uh by the way this is
from my book Sword and Scimitar and it
deals with those battles. Anyway, take a
good look at it. Now returning to Heler
Bell, one can also see how an accurate
understanding of true history as opposed
to an indoctrination in mainstream
pseudo histories leads to an accurate
prognosis for the future. For Bellac was
not only correct about the past but the
future as well. After he wrote that
Islam is quote
the most formidable and persistent enemy
which our civilization has had and may
at any moment become as large a menace
in the future as it has been in the
past. He went on to write quote the
whole spiritual strength of Islam is
still present in the masses of Syria and
Anatolia meaning Turkey of the East
Asian mountains of Arabia, Egypt and
North Africa. The final fruit of this
tenacity. The second period of Islamic
power may be delayed but I doubt whether
it can be permanently postponed.
Make no mistake about it. We are well
into this second period of Islamic
power. And contrary to what Bellac
thought or hoped, not only has a
suicidal West done absolutely nothing to
delay, let alone permanently postpone
this resurgence, it has gone out of its
way to help empower Islam in the West to
its own detriment and demise.
[Music]